guess what it's me hey listen up Gabe
got away got soon hey don't worry
barotrauma is coming at you hot and fast
but first they're going to tell you
something hot and fast like a pizza hey
don't worry you're in the right place I
just have to tell you something before
we get onto the game right now cloak is
celebrating National Unity Day with art
beyond the binary lineup of clothing
we've got some really cool stuff and if
you haven't visited cloak brand.com in a
while we just celebrated our one-year
anniversary you've been working very
hard of the past year to make sure the
prices are going down and we've
introduced new options like after pay so
you can pay an interest-free
installments in addition to that the
beyond the binary lineup of clothing
will put ten percent of the proceeds
towards The Trevor Project and if you
don't know about The Trevor Project
it is a 24/7 hotline for suicide
prevention and immediate intervention
for LGBTQ youth so if you haven't
checked that out in a while go to closer
and comm link right there in the
description check out some of the cool
stuff that we have we've got this shirt
in this great bomber jacket amongst
other things I love this bomber jacket
it's my favorite thing we've ever made
so thank you check it out right down
there
now under the game
if I'm at the helm we're probably gonna
have at least a small amount of crashing
into stuff but that's right okay I trust
you captain I'm gonna be a medical
doctor Oh what the hell no there's
things we have to do oh my god
God cardio oh my god we have to buy
batteries and stuff oh no I'm gonna
spend all my money on shotgun shells oh
here we go baby supplies for ourselves
ah here we go baby
I hope we have something to shoot at
something or something here we go
all right boys oh it's a new ship oh god
oh god of all times for me to be the
medical officer the other bot is a
medical officer morning insufficient
power wait so do we not have are you not
an engineer then mark no I'm not did you
want me to be I didn't think about that
but it was helpful
well I mean you you're gonna have to run
the engines and stuff basically right
fine my god what do you want wait did
you know well no we're just gonna make
we're gonna give way to pass to do
nothing is that what we're gonna do I'm
Gunnar and we have the bots someone one
of the bots I'm here I'm on the engine
duel my god I'm getting yet God just
wait
I have nothing just wait I have no we
need to charge these batteries so before
you go pulling any fancy maneuvers let
the batteries at least charge a bit
we're docked so we can't even move I'm
just gonna stay docked for a minute have
you guys gone all the way up this yeah
there's a way up top area do I want to
enter Kure station am I even out am I
out of the ship right now come all the
way upstairs guys oh well okay I'll
leave the engine alone so I can come
upstairs yeah yeah that's what I'm gonna
do
yeah this is the hatch right here so we
can leave the ship why would you leave
the ship to explore why would you
explore we've got a mission right now
all right Wade don't question what I'm
doing
Wow it's a whole nother ship cool
hey how you doing a Linea do I want to
enter Curie station I don't think so
alright give me give me give me status
updates or whatever crap our batteries
are full we're going I'm putting it back
in automatic control we are good to go
baby I'm going to undock us and we're
gonna begin piloting to Kim Joo outposts
you do is there a front gun somewhere
Jim Joe wait the guns are right here I
found yeah there's like a back one and a
bottom I don't see like a top front like
blast [ __ ] these are the guns man you'd
think there'd be one on the front top of
the sub like that just seems come on man
my first mission can you be just like
not your first mission
there's nowhere near your first mission
dude I've got a gun with morphine in it
with morphine from a distance I think
Bob needs a little bit of repair now Bob
you feeling a little down in the dumps
any little juice a little down the dumps
my dude dude Wow
oh my god so freakin wasted right now Oh
got it bro it shoots an entire syringe
wait no that's not good I just wasted
all of our morphine well I'm gonna put
some random syringes in here we're gonna
steroids in a bit what steroid shot it
of fentanyl I don't know some fentanyl
Oh
what is what is that is that good it's
an extremely powerful painkiller it it
people died from it from overtones all
the time cool I've got some anabolic
steroids if I want that
oh that's I need those make my pee pee
get bigger well ah man wait I hate to
break it to you
I don't think that's how they work I'm
on my knees I'm begging hi we'll all
right fine you're gonna get it right in
your dick oh is it bigger is it getting
bigger
I don't know I'm taking internal damage
oh wait I didn't I didn't shoot you with
the steroids I shot you with something
else I don't know what I'm healing I
shot you with fentanyl Oh God I shot you
a factor though wait no you you didn't
get fentanyl you need fentanyl I'm gonna
get you fentanyl okay right in the dick
[Applause]
opiate overdose oh [ __ ] that's not good
you're fine
boy you're ugly it's so big yes you're
so big
why are you touching me oh wait no sorry
Wade's not ugly you're ugly Bob you're
hideous
oh that's not very nice stop get off of
me
what don't touch me like that I was
wrong I'm your doctor you da good
someone said there was something clawing
on the hole oh my god this is a clogged
on the who the [ __ ] is this what is the
Fricker you get off her hole at some
person it's a human it's a human it was
a human who's trying to mine into our
Hall I blasted the hell out of him I'm
gonna go for
pairen the hole if there is any repair
that needs to be did oh my god it's the
dead bodies are just looking at me look
at this this good left gun oh my god oh
oh that's me that's me do not read this
gun is aimed at you it's fine please
don't okay there's no hole damage
all right good gobbled up Oh grab the
husk mark I will grab the moss grab it
for resources wait they've got fella
they've got eggs I feel like xenomorph
sir here that's not that's not what you
want all right we're gonna start wait
are you are you done out on the outside
are you lost almost almost
are you breathing the infected corpses
into it yeah why I'm sure it's good yes
good
it's good because I say it's good all
right you're the doctor I am a doctor I
am the doctor
you should why wouldn't you are you back
inside mark yes I am yes yeah but I
gotta I'm gonna get us back on course to
Kim Joo hey I'm just gonna keep this gun
aimed at it I think it's dead peachy
they something calling about the help oh
my god maybe left
oh we're slamming into the ground I hear
like breathing looking we're leaking now
I hear the ground well maybe we're not
are your water flowing
yeah we're leaking mark are you running
- yeah yeah and totally all right I've
got both the a ice down there's water
there's water down there they're on it
they're on it but man the water is
rising we still need we still need power
I have no power on the helm I can't yeah
be when I'm trying to get down there to
make a repair but oh it's very wet down
here boss got a leak god I got it I got
it I got it fixed it's fixed it's fixed
wait where are you where are you uh
right here you just walk right by me
wait I've got I've got something for you
oh no no it's fine don't worry about
yeah meet me in the medic here coming to
the medical once you look at these dead
bodies
look where are you we're next in medical
what no you're not who they follow not
me
the Marcela medical medical medical all
right so how much do are we like low on
fuel cells are we gonna be all right
all right do you feel any different No
all right cool
good all right okay what all right
what'd you do to me
nothing hold on okay okay
you look healthy thanks man cool good
all right serum it feels as if something
was stuck in your throat
mark what'd you do to me cool discharge
coil what why did you say that feels
like there's something in my throat why
would there be something in your throat
did you swallow something you did you
put the husk eggs in the waves are you
talking about anybody [ __ ] alien why
you feelin yeah all right Wayne all
right no I'm not there's something at
the stuck in my throat
wait let me let me take a look at you
you look fine you are the doctor but
like also dude you're fine stop
panicking it seems fine to me wait I
don't know what you're freaking out
about just feels like there's like a
little like an alien and you throat like
a tickle in the back of your throat or
something yeah like it as if like maybe
something shoved into me shoved in you
would have noticed if I shoved anything
India wit yeah you definitely would have
noticed I don't know I'm pretty
oblivious I don't know how I can subtly
shove something I feel kind of feverish
dog what do you need morphine I don't
know I feel kind of sick adrenaline give
you adrenaline to lower the fever like
some Tylenol or Fanta mean I got
methamphetamine you want methamphetamine
oh yeah it was meth you know the battle
I don't know if that's I'm married but
I'm not gonna be I'm not gonna give you
anything fine I'm now suffering from
husk infection what that's hard
oh that's no weird typical you feel
something moving in your throat you try
to scream but no sound comes out hey
Medical with me yeah why don't you just
go over to medical okay get in the
corner
all right now we're just gonna observe
you all right yeah we'll just hang out
yeah it's casual casual men see how
casual it is it's casual hey if if I had
to guess you know if you did have a husk
infection I'd say you look about 62%
infected if I could tell that sort of
thing what's up man you can't afford
waste electrical engineering skill
increased too well so great that's
really cool I think you guys have this
under control
I got a saunter I'm back over the pain
if you were at 69% infection then
wouldn't that be cool hey whoa whoa whoa
wait I'd be pretty funny wait wait I
need you to back up there I need I need
I can't what I have I have help what are
you talking about yeah I think I feel
like a mark has been an excellent doctor
so far I've been an incredible doctor
I'm curious what happens not that I can
tell but what happens if he hits a
hundred percent infected I'm also
curious he's at a 79 genuinely curious
about that maybe I don't know but that's
just my guess just by looking at the
color of his skin
yeah well then you can look at his pants
pants that look right yeah it doesn't
look right at all can you cure me aa
cure that listen I need I need to talk
to the medical officer for a minute just
face the corner hey do you uh if any
actual idea what's gonna happen when
he's lying
you know honestly I have no clue I just
kind of shoved the eggs inside of him
I was always that in what huh nothing
listen this is important captain talk
here I shoved everything inside of him
and feels so good guys I have to a eyes
so I we don't really know we don't need
them at all of course that's why I
shoved him full of echo yeah 97 isn't
interesting what happened
a strange shitness appendage burst out
from your mouth oh yeah I see wait no I
oh my god I'm suffering some internal
damage yy8 why need me heal you stop
being such a baby about it yeah let me
heal you here here's some blood yes
blood there you guys blood free does he
needs opium antibiotic glue or more fine
yeah or cow calyx and ID which probably
would kill anything inside him but
something dark and unpleasant moves in
the mouth they are rendered completely
mute safer occasional clicking sounds
appraisal officer I think you got maybe
shouldn't leave you honest man art fine
I think you are just fine he doesn't
look so good ah cat face you kept me
that look so good
got mom maybe you need to give him some
more blood I don't know what I have in
my gun here I got stabbed azulene let's
go better how's that going there haze
healing the internal damage hey look at
that
oh he's good I think you fixed him oh
cool let's get back to the ship let me
go check on the fuel yeah the outpost we
don't know my job yeah probably yeah a
little bit that's a crappy alright hey
where'd he go
oh hey hi there you are hey what's up
man right by that door yeah wow that's a
cool tears away from the kimchi op let's
hit the gas shall we let's just luscious
cut it huh talk so much and now
something outside the ship and I don't
know what it is oh dear goodness what is
it boy it's like a squid suck suck oh
what a sucky suck squid is that good
probably not but you know you never know
with these things
oh I'm killing it before it gets it does
anything to us alright it's dead okay
there's a little hole down it's
hammertime
all right yeah let's just go ahead and
thank you oh that's a big corpse yeah I
know it's a real big thing it was a real
big all right uh-huh yeah hey we're 485
meters away from Kim Joo outpost so
that's really cool you know what else is
in the 80s
oh no wait you're better what do you do
I may have left the a I treat him is he
- is he fine uh well he's not gonna be
helping I think he's fine
I think he's fine if we just let okay
let his body heal him naturally there's
no better treatment than the human body
ya know the body the body knows what it
wants rod he knows the body knows what
it means he is the most wise I'd say
just slap some essential oils on that
maybe some essence of lavender like some
peppermint ah - whoa hey Wow wait are
the reactors okay let me go check okay
drink they're all good in this
neighborhood take his clothes off he's
taking all of his clothes off that's
very weird let me take a look at your
buddy a buddy oh that's that's a lot of
orange and red colors doc is there
anything you can think so I think he
just if he bites down hard he should cut
that tentacle right out wait
now look I'm so good yeah looking good
at all
Jin are I'm in your little bar there is
pretty um oh oh yeah all right well I'm
just gonna go do captain's stuff for a
minute don't so it seems like a doctor's
job whoa hey I'm taking them to medical
get wait let's just get to that outpost
I think we're almost there I think I
think we'll be all right once we once
were we're still only eighty five meters
why aren't you going I didn't know that
anybody could be a hundred and eleven
percent internally damaged that's a lot
of damage okay
all right yeah and now oh I see now he's
going down honestly I have no idea
what's gonna happen eeeh when this bar
hits zero but I'm curious you know I'm
curious I could perform CPR on him I
might be good poof CPR I don't think
this is CP I think
all right we're docked all right good
job okay it says Wade's unconscious
[Laughter]
really hoping that like something would
explode out of you I was trying to
infect everybody but I couldn't do
anything
how did you have like an option no no
okay all I saw was that I was a little
tentacle mouth thing and then the
internal damage probably fine probably
fine hey you know what let's keep this
if we're still on the same thing are you
just gonna feast
are you still fine we will fire that's
cool though I like to like going deeper
deep this this feels like we need to go
deeper here with the procedural missions
and stuff we need fuel rods by the way
we need to buy fuel rods do we want to
terminate a swarm kill a hammerhead or
kill a tiger thresher I don't know that
you want to kill anything without your
gunner cuz it all be very functional how
about we just don't focus on one thing
instead of a swarm
hammerhead or tiger I think a hammerhead
is the thing I killed already so we
maybe can handle that okay let's do that
and I remember we buy we need yeah we
need it's in miscellaneous yeah fuel rod
please how many should I get like we
come up through two and a half so we
need throw at least I'll buy like four
okay that sounds good and if I could
make a medicinal request we probably
yeah that thing that'll cure him which I
believe was it's not first hey tell you
what just buy some various medical
things by one of every like medical
thing you can see and well we'll just
see what happens is there a cure Cthulhu
yes there is I I just need to make it
okay time based on my health and we
wrapped up by like like five of each one
I don't know five of the cheaper ones I
guess I want add this switch so I can
switch back to being alive remember
whatever I was alive and healthy and not
five your fun we're buying we're buying
so much stuff right now it's gonna
absolutely save your life you are going
to be saved
100% saved I'm guys ready for this okay
well a doctor quickly mark I will doctor
so fast a particularly aggressive
hammerhead has been terrorizing vessels
between Kim Joo and Kim Joo wait how you
doing roof to the credits look you're
fine I was way doing he's good he looks
good hey look it's all the chemicals we
bought
oh sweet let me put these away why don't
we have different crew right now what is
this if it all remains and
Rosendo font a sure we got a lot of [ __ ]
oh god I forgot that this game like you
physically have the items where's all
this stuff oh is it just in these crates
yeah it's fine we've got the crates
where's like the fabrication room oh
this is the no that's the rack it's
upstairs actually that's a bit of a pain
yes divide component and the super
capacitors a good idea bought a divide
component I didn't do that
I'm just asking oh my god if we have to
drag all this [ __ ] up here oh my god oh
no is this the is this a wait is this
not on the ship this isn't even on the
ship yeah oh god I can't make any of
this what do you need to make the thing
that you actually need you know what I
don't think we need it cuz Wade's cured
to be perfectly honest yeah I started
off cured is he actually fine he's fine
yeah I don't have any any internal
damage I'm not losing health no weird
red letters across my screen telling I'm
feverish or feel lumps in my throat ah I
need a wrench one of these boxes is
gonna have a wrench we better keep
moving we're chewing up fuel captain oh
and my peepees still big oh I should
have maybe powered off the reactor here
I'm just gonna shut down the reactor so
we stop using fuel I think we can just
we can just hang out docked for a minute
I have a funny feeling it's gonna and
poorly for us no it's fine it's fine
where are we taking these two I don't
know where there is a place that we
could take and do we didn't we didn't
think this through the storage stuff in
the in cabinets and things there's not
enough cabinet space man whatever just
filling up 13 crates here's fine we
should buy more cabinet why do we have
13 11 phosphorus look I bought you said
buy a bunch of stuff I'm gonna save ways
life and I was like we need to save
weights life that's what's important I
feel great I thank you guys for that I
did exactly what you said I ever do
captain
do what you want to do oh [ __ ] we got a
lot of damage here we got a lot of
damage
yeah on this far side of the ship where
there's no gun which is a big flaw in my
opinion I also agree with it okay at
least the whole crews hanging out up
here go baby let's go let's freakin
let's heck and freakin do this huh
hey wait if I find some more eggs do you
mind if I shove them inside you knows
all you know to cure me this time I
don't well these are the loader I might
not do that if I were you stay here
you're strong maybe you should listen to
your captain say your post
Boethius all right what's my person guy
oh [ __ ] you oh my god did you knock him
unconscious Oh give me CPR you dick yeah
die we probably need him that's not CPR
that's not I'm bad now I feel it as good
as you're gonna feel Oh God the way I
hear the squishing OH
what what what what what what once and
say don't do that all right pay
attention you're gone there's bad things
around you never know it's gonna be a mo
and I can't add more to it what put more
ammo in these how do I grab this I got
some more ammo oh thank god you're so
stupid you're impossibly stupid put the
empty ammo box back on the shelves good
man that's good it's good
wait I'm sorry I didn't mean it you're
not stupid I know you're not I didn't
I was about to hit you can while you're
on the parish go but still get back I'll
be nice Oh sounded like it that was it
TV I felt it your vigor is up though so
you're feeling invigorated your your
shot at rental and right into my penis
so I feel your vigor is so hot so figure
is wait look on your thanks for 10
straight hours right now and still have
energy to go for more Oh what's this
notices your vigor sweet vigor oh wait
there's something on the hull oh [ __ ] oh
yeah we're under attack under attack in
our the the one there boy I have someone
on the ran down the one side we can
attack I got some of a man there's a lot
of them they're all dead I think great I
think they're glad that they were around
we're a second we're thinking we're
saying we squished ball bottom right
yeah I know I know I know are we are we
leaking I'm gonna find out we look okay
for now
maybe you shouldn't leave an idiot AI on
it when you could have a smart me but
will do and then I'm not gonna do it do
it I commanded you to do it alright
captain Kevin I think he's putting ah
what was that there was an explosion
wait did you donate it no I did doctor
look I was right next to Bob oh no I
know what it was
you bought potassium right Bob oh yes
when potassium touches water there was a
little identification science said
reacts explosively with water the
container with the potassium in it
exploded oh no I'm not dead save me
where are you I'm in the medical which
is flooding help oh dear
yeah I don't know how do we get over
there on the floor I don't know oh it's
flooding oh boy oh boy you know what
mark if you would help
oh boy
oh man there's flooding everywhere not
ideal hey the leaps are fixed Rosendo
Fonte open the door flooded the room I
was hiding in well now we can get to
where Mark is so that's something hey
Mark how you doing over here oh I
brought some water with me I hope that's
okay I'm gonna you're you you seem to be
Birds on your legs and face oh I
exploded down Oh God yeah you did you
sure did yeah how why did I explode but
you didn't explode I think maybe the
water pressure did you ever shoot no I
should grab one good grab a suit yeah no
it's not apparently Rosendo Fonte is
somewhere there just little there there
planking in the reactor room I think
they're dead straining oh wow
the AI will save you not me cuz I
exploded no crushed my water pressure
burn to death crushed my water pressure
I don't know why of anything that is
because I called you stupid I get it I
feel bad for me if I go to your feet or
I just needed that moment oh my god so
fast yeah first of all they're [ __ ]
explosive we go to see I was there um
once again wait I was there
that you find so funny about it it's how
bullet rent you get work he just can't
stop laughing cuz about angry are we
going again or what are you doing there
doctor
repairing the ship it looked like you
were just running around mass-spring of
machine gun at there huh
preparing this ship just cuz you're too
stupid in your simple Gunners brain to
understand the complexities of ship
repair doesn't mean that you get to
question me well Jodi just question the
captain so I think that's a worse
offense than what I did whatever are we
going are we undocked yes that is cold
at the Lord on dock power power to
thoughts an alien now or undocked oh
[ __ ] we are under holy crap everything
good like rushing water in my ship I
don't go too fast captain cuz I need to
go out and do some oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] captain stop stop the
boat stop over right after stop the boat
some of the boats okay okay okay yeah
yeah it's good it's good as good as good
okay I need to go around do some repairs
okay okay I'm I'm back at the boat okay
I thought that I would keep pace yeah I
didn't realize you go that fast all
right hang on I need to get back inside
I finished the repairs just stop making
fun of me
I hope that my Furies repeat the last
word I said before I died whatever
horrible death fulfilled me sink in here
thank you all right can I go now yeah
you can go now whatever listen things I
do for you people the things I do jump
out of a moving sub for us at all I
thought I could keep pace you know I
thought I could keep pace but you know I
guess I just go out appreciate it how
fast do you think a doctor can swim deep
under the ocean specifically a doctor
doctor all right any state available no
stars like something we are eight 800
meters away from hammerhead were those
things
oh there's some stuff outside there
stuff outside over there in the top
right dead four we all right yeah top
rights dead we can't I can't aim there
top right there's stuff on the top right
of the ship I think we have no gunner I
mean a security officer this is kind of
your does your part of you dude secure
yes sir go up there cleave him off man
Oh God we're taking a lot of whole
damaged security officer you need to get
out there and shoot him
they're dead these are dead top scared
it off it up I can't do top right up we
have no guns cider I don't have a gun oh
my god get outside or open the room so I
can get a gun you big babe I can't I go
there's the room so we're here past the
medical no with the engines what's wrong
with the engines I don't know I can't
move what if I did this harpoon gun I
guess I can take the harpoon gun out
there I I can't move us right now is
there like a current or something
outside the ship
is there a sudra noise go out like this
yeah just go suit you oh my god okay
this is from the suits and Bob are you
going away from the Hammerhead I am I
can't go that way I can't move to the
right I don't understand why is it
leaking
what's the leaking sound oh god it's
damaged wait why are you why are you not
now side head could someone else shoot
that monster thank you you are the worst
you're the worst you are the worst
you're the worst I'm going to check it
out
Oh weird you guys are going down very
fast I wait don't mark me wait are you
are you floating off away from us she's
getting pretty far away from us I think
oh there's very high pressure here the
suits not gonna hold for long no this is
gonna be fine we tired but the suit is
fine oh my god this thing this ship is
[ __ ] what's happening to the ship oh you
left a full of water wait
[ __ ] what there's a hull breach in the
airlock up top oh god you didn't close
the door I didn't close the door you
clearly didn't you clearly didn't wait
are you back in the ship yeah
okay guys oh thank god I literally
closed the door behind me yeah it
doesn't seem right why would you not
close the door behind you when you're
exiting a submarine at a thousand was
already full of water everything in
every room is fine lot to get wet
what room
oh you know it hurts urge Bob love it
hurts it's one of those rooms you go
into that are already wet you know it
hurts but it hurts does it hurt you Bob
my bad driving the boat hurts me this is
painful what's happening I want to
confirm that you did in fact kill all of
the creatures I think you know there's a
leak but I can't kill the ones the
bottom of ship whenever I'm out what
didn't you go to the bottom of the ship
I could never catch up to the ship hull
breach up top hull breach up top all
right going for it I'm going outside
cabin wish me luck okay it wasn't smart
that's my are you really to slam into
the bottom up guy busting I can you
close the can you empty the airlock for
God's sake I didn't closed or did I a
ship we're going up all right okay
airily
all right I'm checking for hulls whoa
that's a monster
Wow God
Oh God get off my Tootsie snare go cold
store come in baby okay I'm better now
I'm all better baby I'm fine Bob Bob
about the drone Bob hey the reactors
broke this engines broken man that loose
we're going up very fast probably good
Bob oh hey Bob Bob Bob hey did we
survive yeah technically we're alive
yeah where were you
ah I thought Lexi was dying but she was
just barking at the neighbors maybe just
came up on our incompetence and left our
incompetence yeah mark I saw you try to
swim with the daughter like an [ __ ]
you're an [ __ ] screaming flailing
around yeah you called my flight my
survival between life and death
he made funny noise you know [ __ ] I just
killed Jody Jesus I'm gonna kill Jody
stop being in this room with me and
we're holding positions prepare any
damage I see okay okay fix Oh oh this is
really damaged okay I ran out of repair
juice but I think I got all the breaches
there's one more breach here but it's I
can get it from the inside so come back
in fun all right why is this game so
funny to me
alright I'm good we go right yeah
everything I say I think we're good we
mentally and emotionally ready for this
all right Wade so next time you go
outside and you kill the busters you
know what's beneath us what how the hell
am I supposed to go down here I don't
understand there's like a hole that
we're not gonna fit through us can you
heal my internal damage the thing is we
are low on medical supplies it seems
like someone like put all of the medical
supplies in a gun and started shooting
at people which is really weird
I thought it's permanently responsible
yeah it was it was very strange
anyway what's wrong with you just
internal injuries all right cool well
I'm coming let me see what I got system
listen you uh how you feel about eggs
yeah I feel pretty good right there you
go that's better
oh my internal damages are gone thanks
man oh my god it's mark actually this
[ __ ] miracle we don't know what else
he did at least one of them healed me
temporarily yeah man yeah you're fine
you find you find any my camera from our
hammerhead 560 we're so far where we
have made zero progress towards actually
take forever no no no I'm gonna check
the engines okay not now on fuel okay
I'm replacing how many sadly spare cells
do we we have one more after this so we
better get we get there oh boy well
we're under 500 meters away from the
Hammerhead they kill it and then go back
it's up to the right we got to kill it
and then make it to the next post I
think that's what we got to do it's the
same one it's Kim Joo and Kim Joo oh but
there are two separate Kim Jews okay got
it
I like being the medical officer I feel
like I got something to do you for the
first time two seconds ago actually
finally Bauer
[Laughter]
my god go to the engineer go to the dama
dama dama de you have to go to the
engine you have to turn thrust down
there's no us it's training everything's
fine anywhere where's the goddamn suit
suit where's the suits right here down
here ya know I gotta find it nope don't
want that suit you wore that doesn't
solve the problem will Hayden
you said you needed a suit I don't need
God
[Music]
I'm gonna lose my I'm gonna lose my mind
Wade I found the leak and I mad I am I
died I'm doing this for us
come on mark fix it I did the the the
oxygen generation is down by the way did
you close that on me no oh my god Bob
Bob I'm gonna I'm gonna lose it what am
I gonna do I am gonna lose it Bob Bob I
am gonna loose it
hey Mark can you heal my internal injury
I have nothing for you mark everything
seems fine where did these suits shoot
just here in the ground these engines
are broken the ends is broken can you
get someone with a wrench that's not the
point
all right everything's good everything's
fine except the compartment where the
engine is but that's fine where you are
you slowly walking to backwards here's a
suit what is a suit here it's a mod
that's my suit it has no no go fill it
with oxygen for you we will refill yes
you can
throw it out the airlock Walker suits
done if you put it back in the suit
Walker does that refill you know it
doesn't heed Earth's oxygen tank the
oxygen generation thingy yeah yeah I
wasn't going to do that to be clear I
just was that wasn't my priority at
night I don't know where the other suits
are here's one down here for some reason
it's down here I started I got it's the
AI they just they wear it and then drop
it wherever they may be all right right
is that one ready to move again yes I
one layer all right we go why did
everything fail before I'm not a hundred
percent sure we lost held power and we
slammed into the ground but I don't know
why we lost helm power okay before we
move let me quickly go around the ship
and make sure we're all sealed up
okay I'm gonna put I'm just put up put
it on maintain position we'll just hover
right here oh there's there's like an up
there's like an updraft coming damn it
god what what oh I'm so stupid I swam
right in front of the engine I got I'm
okay I'm okay I will cast it away into
space okay
I'm fine it's fly make you do that - did
you go I don't see you I'm right next to
the ship I'm right now wide in front of
the engine and I said that I was an
idiot way do you want to take the hit
for it
I'm just surprised as all its character
broken systems I'm sure he doesn't have
a wrench or anything about it yeah your
home's gonna be broken bah
oh well I have a wrench does that help
you have a wrench this whole time yeah
I'm French a helpful you need a wrench
for the wrench doesn't do anything you
need screwdrivers - facial beauty both
alright well there's a wrench for you
I'm gonna put it in I don't wanna call
office go yeah go go go oh there's a lot
of systems broken down there all right
we've all should wait wait one of our
people died worse what metal died Ethel
[ __ ] ansel Oh what was the last thing
Ethel said oh Jesus oh well dead now no
that's not good tanks did you go outside
to die
complicated in a suit with no oxygen got
a cool hey can you say wait Jody doing
the Ethel get off of Ethel I hear the
bigot we still have so many broken
systems Joey's not fixing stuff Jody's
touchy awful job Jody is not fixing it
Jody go fix [ __ ] all right wait I got a
screwdriver from Jody and Ethel's body
oh [ __ ] mark can you give give it here
or come fix my helm because I think the
Helms about all right hang on okay you
know what my injuries hurt give me your
screwdriver Yeah right
it's right here in the supplies Oh Dee
what do you want top why is if what you
did you tell him to follow you or
something wanna go fix [ __ ] Jody do it
up yeah do it
no [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah get it mark all right wait we
are 250 meters away from the Hammerhead
if it stopped right I can't do anything
I mean that's where it will be but I'll
help go get your guns in range or
something
I don't think Jody has screwdrivers and
stuff anymore oh crap yeah I think
somehow Jody lost it can we give it to
Jody because he does when I tell him to
fix stuff he actually does fix it he's
actually an engineer I think Jody is a
Shiba all right does the Paris employees
on their body I didn't have time to
check I grabbed the screwdriver from her
dead corpse I pried it out of her hands
they're called dead hands if that's what
you're asking
swear to god she was I think she asked
for oxygen tanks and then died I was
just coming to check
where's holls dead body in medical cody
is doing dick and diddly Jody is stuck
in a loop on the stairs Ethel died in
there we go and then Jody suddenly
started working what what you put on the
suit that Ethel died and Judy's just
started going at it
Ethel roleplay Jody's fixing stuff now
yeah she's now she's going yep there she
goes she's gone that was over all right
let's kill this from her head yeah let's
do this
perfect position under it with the upper
gun blasting do you appreciate that mark
I thought I was going insane I'll be
helpful anyway just like
I think silence 118 meters to dock and
we need to fix the freaking leak in the
hole I can't reach it it's in the armory
wait okay we're faced wave got you lock
don't know where the leaking bumps
where's the leak I don't know I don't
see any water in the ship itself Cody's
just standing in the doorway Joe do you
know she's sabotaging us she's friends
with a hammer
Jody injured no Jody's arrives in chat
what's happening Jody's fine
Oh Jody's not moving alright Jody Jody I
don't know Jody's why was there water
there ok I need to fix you guys Jody
point is it cuz the radio headsets
broken maybe I don't know I said
that's it oh god dude we just gotta get
get there cuz so 56 metres 55 in closing
okay good I'm just slam it in here for a
quick session that nearly killed me yeah
[Applause]
there we go
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
mistakes but it's fine
all right cool good game guys we'll pick
up this campaign later yeah no I make
sure we say make time I mean honestly I
feel like if we play this game we've
only went through two mission believe we
didn't die that's true cool as always
I'll see you
[Music]